hello everyone and welcome to another
very exciting game from the Dos Hermanas
Tournament of 1996 was played in Spain
udit pogar versus vessel in topalov and
um it's it's a really funny game where H
you can really see how both players
really want to attack and both udit and
vesselin have been known for their
Fierce aggressive Styles and sometimes
um there's no way to attack but you
still want to attack and sometimes it
will cost you uh well it will cost you
dearly uh so in the previous video I
said 10 of the strongest players in the
world have gathered in this tournament
the to play okay nine players plus one
local player um Miguel Cordoba he was
world number 29 at the time but uh all
the other are definitely the top the top
nine in the world so we're going to
discuss that understandings a little bit
after we check out the game but for now
let's see what happened here so you has
the white pieces and she opens with E4
and this is round three uh unit started
with two draws drawing Kik and Shiro in
round one and two we have Pawn to C5
Knight to F3 we have Pawn to D6 and pawn
to D4 we have captures captures not with
the Knight but with the queen and now
Bishop to D7 velin avoids the the main
stuff with Knight to C6 attacking the
Queen Bishop B5 uh pinning the Knight
and after Bishop D7 then Queen to D3 uh
instead he plays a waiting move Bishop
to D7 and now Knight to C6 is definitely
uh well somewhat of a threat so she
plays Pawn to C4 makes sense pretty much
always against the Sicilian when your E4
Pawn is not attacked you can play the C4
move and play this um marozi structure
Knight to C6 we have Queen back to D2
and now Pawn to G6 vesin prepares to
faneto his dark Square Bishop uh an odd
move for this position but it can be
played of course B3 we have Bishop to G7
attacking the rook and now Knight to C3
you could immediately counter it with
Bishop to B2 you prefers to keep the the
pieces on the board we have Knight to F6
and now Bishop to B2 uh Bishop to G4
putting pressure on the Knight Bishop to
E2 castles and pawn to H3 now kicking
away the bishop but Vaseline trades here
Bishop captures and now Knight to D7 REM
maneuvering the Knight to C5 or E5
depending on what unit plays we have
castles and now Queen to A5 and it is
now as of move 13 that we have a
completely new game and uh Rook eight B1
is played uh with the idea of A3 B4 so
you will have additional support for B4
if the Knight and bishop move makes
sense definitely and The Rook is on A1
so you kind of don't want it don't want
it there uh Rook F to d8 we have Rook F
to C1 and now Pawn to A6 we have Pawn to
A3 and Bishop to F6 adding additional
support to the uh E7 Pawn uh we have
Bishop to G4 now putting pressure on the
Knight here and pawn to E6 and finally
Pawn to B4 so nothing unusual happening
here all very nicely done Queen to G5
Vin now offers a queen trade and you
lounes forward with Pawn to F4 we have
Queen to H6 uh and now Knight to E2
gaining more control over the D4 square
but offering a trade of the Bishops so
Knight D to E5 uh the queen on D2 is
undefended so this is why vessel uses
this move to REM maneuver his knight uh
and also avoids trading the Bishops for
the moment Rook to C2 The Queen Is Now
defended and the Knight has to move and
Knight captures on G4 now uh her strong
light Square Bishop gets eliminated
although of course you could argue how
strong it really was H captures and G4
we have Bishop captures and B2 and Rook
B captures and B2 uh Queen to H4 going
after the G4 pawn and here's where
things start to get really really
interesting how do you react to this
position uh objectively best is to
ignore the pawn and to play Rook to B3
why this is so well uh Black's main idea
is to sort of disrupt the pawns with E5
but here it would be a big mistake due
to Rook to H3 Queen captures on G4 and
pawn to F5 closing the position and now
Rook C3 and Rook G3 are coming H this
would be uh well close to close to loss
for black on the other hand if you just
capture the G4 Pawn then the idea is
Rook to H3 and again you will bring the
Rook to G3 or F3 or depending on what
black plays it will still be a very very
nice position however uh she decided to
defend the pawn she played Pawn to G5
but now veselin throws in Pawn to
F5 now you don't have time for Rook to
B3 so Pawn to B5 attacking the Knight a
captures C captures and Knight to D4 you
have to either move the Rook or or trade
here so she trades Knight captures e
captures and now Rook to B3 defending on
A3 and also getting ready to REM
maneuver The Rook over to the king side
if needed we have Rook to E8 Ving puts
pressure on the E4 Pawn uh and here you
have to decide how you want to play play
this uh objectively it's an equal
position and it could be a dead draw uh
all all depends on what um you decides
to play like if she captures on D4 uh
it's it's a draw just Queen T1 check
King H2 Queen H4 check and we go back
and forth back and forth back and forth
or uh if uh maybe black doesn't want to
draw right away you can play Queen
captures on F4 but it's still going to
be a fairly quick draw Rook to C7 now
the idea is Rook F3 to go after the F7
Pawn now we're going to trade Rook
captures an E4 and after Queen F2 uh now
you trade or let's say B6 and now you
trade Queen captures an F4 Rook captures
Rook to B7 and it's a drawn Rook end
game everything pretty much gets traded
down D5 Rook will capture on B6 you're
going to go for the A4 pawn and once the
the D Pawn Falls let's say Rook captures
on A3 Rook captures Rook captures Rook
captures here uh once you play Rook to
B3 and put the Rook behind the pass Pawn
there's no really way to make any
progress here and it's equal material so
it is a draw so so the choice here is to
go for a quick draw or for maybe you
know let's play a few moves and then we
withraw but you did not uh interested in
that she wants the uh she wants to fight
and she wants more than a draw she
already played against Kik she Drew him
Drew shirov now she wants to win against
theal of G3 and okay Queen to G4 and now
comes Queen captures on G4 so without
the possibility of um westling going for
that F4 Pawn H but he does have one move
that uh really keeps him in the game and
that is Rook to A4 the queen is over
overextended here uh guarding both the
D1 Square because the black queen really
wants to come to D1 and also guarding
the E4 Pawn uh so what do you do here
well you can't really capture if you
capture then Queen to D1 check and
you're going to pick up the king with
check Rook with check as well and okay
the king will defend the E4 Pawn along
with the queen but now Rook to C8 then
Rook to C4 and that's pretty much it uh
White can resign this so instead after
Rook A4 you played Rook to C4 uh he
traded once captures captures but now uh
Rook to C8 comes with Tempo that's the
difference rather than in the position
uh a few moves ago so here is uh the
moment where I'm sure you guys could
really make a good move uh because udit
messed up a little bit here uh what do
you play here uh you have the white
pieces Rook to see8 was played what do
you play I'll give you a couple of
seconds
yeah so for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations on finding
Queen to F1 as uh I I've been looking at
this position as much as I could and it
is the only move that makes sense to me
simply because it covers the C1 Square
uh but that's probably one of the one it
was probably one of those moments where
you have to be of a certain strength to
play a to play a B bad move because you
saw saw so much more uh only you know
not uh not the Perfection maybe the
reason why Queen to F1 is so strong uh
is that it of course guards Rook to C1
and now if you play Rook to C2 with the
idea of Shifting the queen to C8 and
Rook to C1 to win the White Queen it
doesn't work Rook to F3 will be played
and now after Queen to C8 going for
let's say Rook to C1 doesn't really do
anything Queen to D3 and you're happy
here if Rook to C1 checking to G2 there
there's nothing here however after Rook
to C8 UD did not play Queen to F1 she
played Queen to D3 uh but now Rook to C1
is uh very very much deadly because
after Rook to C1 check King to G2 of
course you see the only winning move for
topalo uh and topalo of course played it
Queen to H5 going after queen to queen
to H1 check and there's no good way to
avoided this there are no checks there
are no tricks she played Pawn to E5 but
now just Rook to D1
not even rushing with Queen to H1 check
Queen to F3 was played offering a trade
of Queens but of course he goes for
Queen to H1 check King to F2 and uh even
though he could end the game with a
check m in two like Queen G1 check King
to E2 and now Queen to E1 will be
Checkmate uh he decided to go for
something else he played Rook to F1
check he decided to win the queen and he
was in this position un move 37 that U
pogar resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here so really
really wonderful game uh where both of
them played a very active chess very
interesting chess but you just wasn't
satisfied with the draw she wanted to
push for more and the veline punished
her with a couple of very very precise
moves starting with that Rook to A4 uh
Rook lift and yeah we've already checked
out the standings in the couple of
previous videos but yeah you know topalo
also finished shared first with Kik and
six out of nine and pgar after losing
this game uh did did not have the best
tournament she finished on three out of
Nine Zero wins three losses and six
draws uh but yeah and the The Local Hero
Miguel Cordova that we've mentioned that
was only world number 29 at the time uh
invited to this prestigious tournament
or rather he's a local hero all the
other nine were invited actually
finished on four and a half out of nine
he only won one game but he was
unbeatable uh yeah he he got seven draws
so no one could beat him I think only
only Anand defeated him in this
tournament so very nicely done by him uh
but yeah that's the game sometimes you
know it's always great to push for more
it's always uh you know the spirit of a
great warrior to push for a win in an
equal position sometimes it goes your
way sometimes it doesn't uh so yeah hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank
Welsh fan wangan Sasha vidler Mark
Henley Brennan and Michael mes for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up on
you one ful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the Chess World as so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day